hey birdie bid oh oh oh hey buddy whoa
what the heck is going on with that ah
ah why is this so slow ah hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to player unknowns battlegrounds
I seem to be experiencing some technical
difficulties in terms of oh that's
better all of a sudden is it working as
it were as it's working yes and a second
let me see some - done seems fine I
guess I guess it's okay
maybe it's alright maybe it's not I have
no idea but either way you guys are here
and enjoying this stream oh my god what
oh yeah okay I'm trusting it I'm
believing in it I'm believing in the
heart of the cards hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to player
unknowns battlegrounds so if it is being
all sorts of broken then you guys will
let me know very soon but if it's not
then I'm gonna just get back into the
game here and we'll see what's going on
so oh no yes there we go yeah it's fine
it's fine
hi guys so welcome to this old yonder
stream as many of you may noticed I was
missing yesterday
I was just gone from the face of YouTube
I was just nowhere to be found everyone
was searching high and low for where I
was but alas I was untraceable
unfindable in the entirety of youtube no
one could find where I was and who I was
and where I who was and who did what I
know where that was so with that being
said I I have an explanation for you of
some sort I think there's still little
little ik camera is laggy a little bit
night no idea why there is why is
that that shouldn't be that way but it
is and I don't know I'm gonna find out
why but why is that happening
hang on oh I should have tested it huh
okay give me one second one hi hello can
you all hear me huh huh I don't know
what you talkin about I was never gone
in the first place I don't know what in
the world you're talking about so hello
hi my name is markiplier let me know
when you guys can see me again oh you
can a little bit oh hi guys yes so I'm
back I had to fix a problem there Oh Oh
No do I agree I can't get out of here
get out of here with that noise I didn't
even know that was possible to invite
someone who's not a friend how it
changed that I don't have any friends I
fly solo my entire life no one even
knows who I am no one can know who I am
alright so whatever it's gonna refuse
that one I'm gonna get into the game
because I don't want to play with nobody
here so I have a little bit of an
explanation to give for yesterday it's
nothing terrible happened like don't
know everyone who seemed to be worried
that oh my god he's taking a day off
everything must be horrible in his life
but in reality that is not the case
hello lag there we go I'm in hi I'm the
world's greatest markiplier fan does
anybody else want to join me on this
adventure
so with yesterday I took a little bit of
a breather because I was getting
frustrated and not frustrated with
making videos I don't want anyone to
think that I was frustrated with trying
to do everything all at once and that
was like the key source of all my
frustration because in in my ambition
and I have a lot of ambition oh you
won't try to fight me huh huh the naked
markiplier fans gonna fight all you but
in my ambition to
do everything it ended up so that I was
able to do nothing and so I was getting
so frustrated with trying to be the best
that I could be at everything that I
didn't actually do anything you know
what that juxtaposition there's so many
opportunities for you to do stuff and
your inability to capture them you know
it just adds up so frustrating so the
day before yesterday I got really
frustrated and I was just like man I do
so much that I want to do and I just
feel I feel like I can't focus on any
one thing because there's so many
different things that I got for why are
we on fire already this doesn't seem
right hang on a second I think there's
something wrong hello oh yeah okay holla
all right whatever so if you don't know
about this game you you you should drop
into a into a Death Zone and then you
got trying to find guns dayz style and
kill each other so that's what I'm going
to be doing while I try to focus I'm
talking about what I whatever the hell
I'm talking about which isn't a whole
lot but that being said okay there I go
ha so must be so cold and I'm gonna go
over this way I've only played this a
few times and I'm not particularly good
at it
I tried to record an episode but the
recording failed so it's even a wonder
that it's working here but either way I
got frustrated with not being able to do
anything so I took yesterday as like a
reset day when I said I was taking a
break I wasn't actually taking a break I
actually worked out a whole lot I I
focused on writing a list of goals
trying to identify what exactly I wanted
to do with my life and what exactly I
wanted to do with like what I was doing
on YouTube and the future after YouTube
and stuff like that and so it was just
really nice to be able to kind of focus
on that idea and so that's what I did
and it was really nice because it let me
like it let me really really really get
a
and I actually intended to post videos
yesterday but I was so I'm so
preoccupied with like my planning and
whatnot that it actually ended up that
uh I I just kept the day off and I don't
know it was just really good it was
really good to have a soft reset on you
know what I was doing and so when I took
a break it was more of a mental vacation
focusing on the things and also
narrowing down mrs. pants pants what is
this pants [ __ ] smoke grenades yeah
is gonna help me yeah but I want to get
smoked up huh anyone want to smoke me
out huh
nobody okay no guns huh no guns nah
nothing I got a grenade I got smoke
grenades that's all I got no one better
mess with me I'm gonna smoke that [ __ ]
out of them okay I guess I can top that
there we go
so yeah I took yesterday as a reset and
I went missing and a lot of people
worried but there was no reason to worry
because in all honesty oh good more
smoke grenade oh that's gonna help me
aw it's gonna really was that against
ken or something no it's nothing usable
well this ain't good hmm
got a whole lot of nothing here a helmet
I got pants and a helmet all right I am
unstoppable all right anything over here
see I don't know I don't know all the
spawn layouts or anything like that I
don't if there's certain rules for where
things can only spawn in certain places
but I'm probably going to get blasted
into Kingdom Come eventually here but I
got nothing so I'm just gonna you know
wander aimlessly without guns or
anything that can help me
cuz I'm a helpless baby right
I got a smoker throws no grenade fur
though no one's gonna know where
now they're gonna be looking at all the
smoke ha ha ha my master plan it's fun
he come to fruition well I'm the
shirtless wanderer wandering the streets
of this broken city and I'm gonna die a
real heart at least I'm in the circle
that's awfully nice I bet there's gonna
be a bunch of people in this it was that
a Jeep over there thought I saw a
vehicle after I clear this red zone it
started well I'm not near that so I
don't need to worry about it all right
what do we get we really do badoo badoo
hope no one shoots me in the face boob
should be Boop a little bit a bit but it
Boop
anybody home anybody home anybody want
to get in a fistfight
I got grenades got nothing else I got
hope in my heart but that's it hope
don't get you stopped from being shot uh
hmm whole lot of nothing a whole lot of
nothing huh
is that what I got prescribed here whole
lot of dick diddly a dot a lot of dick
diddly doo - oh well that's handy I'll
take that whoa whoa huh yeah I reload
this bad boy here all right
so Marquis mu found Gunny Wu and Marquis
mu is not gonna use it effectively no
matter what Marquis mu do so Marquis mu
restricting the play area now we're good
we're fine did I hear someone tip
steppin someone skip stepping over in my
town huh all right going for the next
one yeah
anybody in here hello Peter anybody
anybody no open doors either someone's
very tidy about closing the door by
number there's no one here let's see if
I baseball cap no I don't want to go
I'll stick with the helmet there can I
get the sickle thanks compensator for a
sniper rifle that
don't have well there's an AKM that
seems cool not enough space huh alrighty
then
well it doesn't really do me a lot of
good if I have everything nada not uh
not a goddamn how do I drop this I drop
[ __ ]
yeah there we go let's see let me get
the seven six - but I didn't pick up the
oh I did pick up the AKM so I don't have
a nine millimeter so I'm gonna take this
come on pick it up please oh come on
alright then I'm gonna drop this I'm
gonna drop my delightful smoke grenades
whoa well that ain't good who's shootin
out there huh whose shoe stood in my
city huh whose shoe stood out there Oh
seems good seems fine someone shoe stood
out there much care for it huh uh no I
don't see no one mmm
maybe I should announce my presence I
would have thought that more people
would have been in this city but
apparently the answer is not there is
someone out there okay
so they restrict a play area over time
so you see that blue circle moving in
towards the edge there that means that
the anyone outside of that circle is
going to take damage so people are
forced to fight together in a box
uh-huh
okay why no coward I'm gonna go up to
the roof
that's what cowards do right or that's
what big brave boy do right pants more
pants a ballistic mask ooh
combat combat pants I'll take these
combat pants can I get a combat shirt I
really go well with my outfit here hmm
don't see nobody all right then
not a lot of action going on in this one
ever seems everyone seems to be hiding
away
I mean much like myself I'm doing plenty
of hiding but don't get me wrong I'm a
coward first aid kit P 245 ammo nothing
I need there I'm fine
I'm not gonna nothin I'm gonna make it
to the end of this but I'm gonna try my
best okay
alrighty then come at me come at me
everyone in the world and bails on the
ruse here there's more Grenada this I'm
gonna drop the drop this cuz I don't
need it actually I don't do I need the
sickle in case I want to smash someone
in the face
yes drop that - seven six not enough
space why is there not enough space for
the goddamn ammo I've got I've got so
much space finally drop the smoke grade
that I need so much 45 45 P me all right
well at least I got another backup
weapon not that I know that I'll need it
or nothin was that glasses nice I can't
see myself but I assume
like rad anybody here nobody here
apparently hello hello the circle is
closing in hmm
53 left last night look there were 60
what happened to everybody everybody's
dying they're dropping like flies
okay doodly-doo doodly-doo I'm the
shirtless guy with a gun no doodly-doo
doodly-doo Oh
holographic sight that seems nice
um drop that pick up that attach that
attach that that oh yeah whoa hello
who's there oh come back come back
please
they're coming back where they at where
they at okay I hear him out there do you
guys hear them I don't know if the audio
is good enough so that you guys can hear
them but I can hear them okay
[Music]
where's he at whoopee
is that oh this is an airdrop
[Music]
this game is like every time that I
played it and I haven't played it too
much but every time that I played it
it's like if you can get a sniper rifle
you're gonna win or at least you're
gonna get pretty close cuz like sniper
rifle is like game over you can just sit
in a spot and kind of camp there forever
and ever oh yeah
oh yeah I don't know what the red zones
are for other than that they're bombed
incredibly all right so I'm gonna stop
being a coward I'm gonna get out there
Michelle these guys what for and who
what and who did what to who and where
oh I see that vehicle oh is that the
same wild come back go come back
wanna play nice okay well I'm in the
play area marked on the map so that
means people are going to be coming this
way
eventually it's like I coming back
because I think he went towards the way
let me just reload this one just in case
all right see what we can do about this
I'm a big brave boy with a big gun no
one gonna mess with me I mean everyone's
gonna mess with me and I'm gonna get
shot in the head now I'm never gonna get
a single kill but that's just a fact I
hear someone rumbling around out there
I had a vehicle of my own I'd have fun
with it hey Mike Rosie ha ha ha alrighty
then that's kind of nice we love this
one just in case just in case I need to
spray someone with like an unimaginably
huge amount of bullets ok
babban it boo how about a tender look
ooh
quiver well I don't have a crossbow so
that doesn't work for me okay
hellooo
backpack whoo that's handy that can I
have that cool helmet well that seems
cool
nice looking all sorts of armor except
for all my chests which is the most
important apart on my body mommy I guess
the brain is also pretty important to
protect but I'm just saying it doesn't
seem to be working out so well for me
wonder how many people are just camping
around in here pants just pants pants
nothing no shirt for markimoo
gotta show off the sweet abs I've been
working on that are non-existent and
don't actually are real that no one
knows about cuz they're not actually
there I just lie about it bullet loops
what does it even mean I don't know what
that meant but okay where's the play
area I'm still inside it
oddly enough wonder if it's going to
come down to everyone being in this city
all by themselves
alright nope no shirred energy drink
hell yeah bruh yeah poke my head up just
like that that's good umm I see nobody
Oh
they died outside the play zone cuz
they're dumb huh no one there all right
moving on
mmm okey-dokey then
anybody man I wish these beat-up
jalopies weren't all here I would is
that a real one it's not a real one I
think that might be a real legit car I'm
gonna take it for a joyride if it is oh
is it
is it really could it be for true oh no
it's it's [ __ ] never mind
that's a rusted piece of [ __ ] if I ever
saw one all righty then
Carrie whoo that doors open well that
doors open oh is that the way we're
playing this huh
either someone was here and they left or
someone is still here all righty then I
think someone just came through here or
maybe this door was already left open
but either way I'm skewed I'm so skewed
you think I can drive that thing you
think that strippable
you think that big old jalopy over there
is drivable oh yeah maybe maybe okay
i'ma try office uh plus see I don't know
open here the worst place I could
possibly be Oh looks broken is [ __ ]
already then anybody in the church tower
no really it seems like there would be
other people in this town but they're
not here now all right is it
this is a bunch of beat-up old cars and
me walking in the middle of the goddamn
road like a goof who a shout gun no I
don't want that oh I sure I found a
shirt I found a shirt I found a shirt
hey can I switch and switch this out for
the show oh it's gun is that a hand
grenade can I have that sweet sweet all
right so I got me a shoe skin don't know
what good that's gonna do for me but
maybe I can hide over here no no find me
no I'm gonna find me it's good vantage
point I guess Oh
ooh I gotta make it I gotta make it to
that area ooh
that means there's got to be a mass
exodus out of this town I don't know if
I want to be a part of that maybe maybe
I can take advantage of it though hey is
where things get scary
oh oh oh yeah
oh whoa who's there who's there
okay bye can I get a ride he don't want
to be your friend that guy's bucking
head oh they coming back oh they just
flanked right okay well they're having
fun and these doors are open which does
not bode well well yeah that's that's
what I wanted to do okay can't do that
apparently that's illegal ooh I see
someone I see someone gonna shoot him
dead I'm gonna shoot him dead where'd
you go
well I see him Oh shades too far oh I'm
coming for you I'm coming for you I'm
coming for you
a
did you go in one of these buildings or
did he go further oh I gotta get moving
I'm almost there but not quite ooh
alrighty then
yeah it's a bad idea
gotta hide behind this rock and ride
this bad boy into the play area oh boy I
feeling I'm gonna get I'm gonna get
sniped so hard just walking out in the
field here I might get destroyed from
that town probably oh yeah I'm gonna get
shot from here yeah that's a perfect
vantage point to get shot hope no one
sees me and shoots me see you see you
though oh I see you
oh I see you alright okay alright okay
okay that's how you want plan huh
running away from me Oh
they didn't spot me but man that that
car is too fast
wrap it wrap it dude wrap it wrap it
yeah Oh Oh Boing Boing Boing Boing
so people are over in that little Villa
there which is cool man I mean I'm at 21
I'm at 21 I haven't shot a single person
not that I haven't tried but no one's
been around here ooh that's scary
well that's Kiwi okay well I'm a little
far away so I'm and I just I'm a bucket
over there fast as I can stick to the
shadows and hope for the best
I don't know if it's going to work out
for me but no one spotted me yet no one
even knows that markiplier fan 69 is
here
I'm gonna wait on the outskirts Oh whose
vehicle is that huh there's multiple
vehicles that's someone up there okay
just gonna crawl commando-style gonna
get there I'm okay without a single kill
I'm not I'm shocked I've made it this
far only through sheer luck and
determination and complete random
[ __ ] have I made it thus far Lee I
imagine there's got to be snide
over the place this is gotta this is how
this got to work Oh boom bang boom bang
boom alright whoa it's somebody's dune
buggy why is there a dune buggy here
whoa who did that
whoa whoa ah who's shooting me ah who do
next
ah no alright well that made sense oh
well got 18 it's alright it's okay I
didn't actually expect to succeed that's
alright though I think I was being shot
from two different angles there like
there was definitely someone from behind
me and then in front of me both shooting
me but alas that is the way that the
world works so anyway that's all the
time that I got for this little
livestream I just wanted to do a really
quick one and I I just wanted to also do
this because it's it this seems like the
kind of game you got to play live for
people to watch with fighting nails to
see how bad you're gonna suck so either
way thank you everybody so much for
watching there's going to be a whole lot
of videos coming your way very soon and
if you check out tomorrow you're gonna
see something very very cool so thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
buh-bye